they did an experiment with a group of
women and they put scars on their faces
and they told these women that they're
going into a job interview and the
purpose of the experiment is to find out
whether people with facial
disfigurements face discrimination they
showed them the scars in the mirror the
women saw themselves with the scars and
as they LED them out of the room they
said we're just going to touch it up a
little bit and as they touched it up
they removed the scar incompletely so
the women went into the job interview
thinking that they are scarred but
actually being their normal selves and
the result of the experiment is that
those women then came back reporting
massively increased level of
discrimination many of them came back
with comments that the interviewer had
made that they felt were referencing
their facial disfigurement this is why I
think this ideology of victimhood is so
dangerous because if you preach to
people constantly that we're all
oppressed then that primes people to
look for that